quelli che è stato dentro dicendo come
sapete tutte anno
manuale di istruzioni per fare altre
cellule manuale di istruzioni che il dna
ci sono circa 20mila pagine in questo
manuale ognuna è un gene
eppure un piccolo errore una parola
sbaglia una lettera sbagliata
in uno di questi fogli può causare una
malattia genetica grave con conseguenze
anche devastanti se però è un istruzione
che è sbagliata non possiamo intervenire
e aggiungere un foglio supplementare di
informazioni che vadano a correggere
questa è l'idea alla base della terapia
genica i geni e diventano farmaci che
noi somministriamo a una cellula preso
da un organismo oppure direttamente
nell'organismo per correggere un difetto
genetico o talvolta se vogliamo essere
ancora più ambiziosi per istruire una
nuova funzione per inserire però i geni
nel dna delle cellule dobbiamo essere
particolarmente efficienti non sono
facili da trasportare i geni tra una
cellula e l'altra al cielo sono gelosi
della loro identità
chi lo sa fare bene in natura sono i
virus quindi l'idea della terapia genica
e usare i virus come dei cavalli di
[ __ ]
rifacendomi a questo mito fondazionale
della nostra cultura mediterranea in cui
c'è la dissimulazione c'è l'inganno ma
c'è anche l'astuzia di achille che aveva
nascosto i guerrieri greci nel cavallo
che i troiani si portano in casa
pensando questi è un dono degli dei
come fanno i virus a entrare nelle
cellule soprattutto si portano dietro i
loro geni le istruzioni per fare altri
virus
quando il giro da solo è capace di vita
autonoma sfrutta la cellula per produrre
altre particelle
quando però lascia la cellula si deve
portare dietro alle sue informazioni i
suoi geni e li va a pescare tra le
migliaia di altri perché questi geni
hanno una sorta di codice codice postale
un punto virus com se volete con cui si
porta via solo i suoi geni allora in
laboratorio
noi possiamo usare questo punto virus
com è in realtà attaccarlo al gene
terapeutico che vogliamo inserire nella
cellule poi il nostro virus diventa
questo cavallo di [ __ ] che entra nella
cellula e riporta non i suoi geni
ma il gene terapeutico se vogliamo in
questo caso è il virus che diventa che
viene ingannato in questo meccanismo che
porta dentro la cellula un gene utile e
che rimane e istruisce una nuova
funzione o correggere un difetto
genetico se quella cellula la passa alle
cellule figlie rimarrà funzionale questo
si può fare in modo ancora più efficace
se noi usiamo delle cellule un po
particolari che sono le cellule
staminali per esempio quelle del sangue
che si mantengono nell'organismo a lungo
e generano tutta una progenie di cellule
che poi vanno a diffondersi attraverso
il sangue nei vari tessuti isolando le
cellule staminali del sangue
introducendo quindi un gene terapeutico
noi possiamo generare tutta una progenie
e possibilmente anche per la vita di un
individuo di cellule della serie bianca
della serie rossa delle varie cellule
del sangue che potranno diffondersi
nell'organismo e correggere dei difetti
genetici gravi come malati da lì
dell'immunità malattie del sangue come
le tasse mie ma anche malattie da
accumulo nei nei tessuti dove mancano
nella malattia genetica
il modo per smaltire questi tessuti
quali stata però la principale
difficoltà per molti anni nel campo a
fronte di questa idea
in fondo semplice di introdurre i geni e
di avere un cavallo di [ __ ] efficiente
a sufficienza per entrare nelle cellule
umane in modo adeguato e qui l'idea è
stata di pensare davvero a prendere un
pochino più il coraggio con le mani di
usare un virus così temibile come rai
hiv il virus dell'aids che però ahimè è
anche un virus estremamente efficiente
per entrare nelle cellule umane
addomesticare questo virus in modo
efficace e rendendo da una parte sicuro
ma dall'altra mantenendo nell'abilità di
entrare nelle cellule e diventare un
veicolo in questo caso amichevole per
noi lavorare con un virus che è stato ed
è tuttora una delle pesti principali che
sa che ha colpito l'umanità lasciando un
numero drammatico di morti e che
continua a essere un virus di cui per
verso cui non dobbiamo abbassare la
guardia non vuol dire però che non si
posta in realtà utilizzando la
tecnologia
renderlo sufficientemente sicuro come
veicolo e in questo caso un virus quindi
così neutralizzato che diventa capace di
portare un messaggio terapeutico
benefico nelle cellule un lavoro che
abbiamo fatto
come avete visto per più di 15 anni
prima di arrivare alla sperimentazione
sull'uomo con il supporto cruciale di
una fondazione come quella di telethon
che ci ha aiutato negli anni ha creduto
in questa idea e che ha portato oggi a
poter veramente dire che questo per una
volta finalmente una sorta di rivincita
se non siamo presi contro questo virus
così temibile perché abbiamo potuto con
le belle parole che ha detto il corriere
in questo articolo riportare il sorriso
sono se su tanti bambini che altrimenti
oggi non avrebbero avuto la possibilità
di vivere una vita senza questo
intervento terapeutico bambini che come
vedete vengono un po da tutto il
mediterraneo e anche fuori che possono
avere su con queste nuove approcci una
speranza di trattamento in realtà si può
andare anche oltre la malattia genetica
con la terapia genica si può per esempio
in di istruire le cellule a fare
qualcosa che non sapevano fare per
esempio attaccare un tumore le cellule
dell'immunità
come sapete sono delle cellule capaci di
uccidere una cellula in un tessuto e per
uccidere questa cellula usano un
recettore sulla loro membrana che fa
riconoscere queste cellule tumorali
piuttosto che altre però spesso non lo
sanno fare
noi possiamo in laboratorio costruire
dei recettori molto efficienti che
possono andare verso il tumore possiamo
con il virus che vi dicevo prima
inserire questi nuovi recettori nella
cellula dell'immunità rendendola quindi
più intelligente
uno dei problemi che troviamo però che
questa cellula aveva già un suo
recettore quindi in realtà ci troviamo
in una cellula confusa che a questo
punto segue due segnali diversi non
sappiamo esattamente come si comporterà
di nuovo l'intervento della terapia
genica possa servirci in che modo
provando a fare i chirurghi chirurghi
del dna stesso andando a sostanzialmente
eliminare il gene che dentro quella
cellula istruiva il suo recettore quello
originale che non ci serve più
tagliare praticamente il dna in quel
punto specifico possiamo farlo perché
abbiamo imparato in laboratorio a
decifrare il codice di quelle proteine
che leggono
ma non ovunque ma sulla base della sua
sequenza specifica abbiamo potuto
decifrare questo codice possiamo quindi
costruire in laboratorio delle molecole
artificiali che vanno a legarsi a
riconoscere il dna dove c'è una
specifica sequenza quindi un punto che
noi abbiamo scelto per esempio in quel
gene che vogliamo tagliare ea questo
punto possiamo in attivare quel gene la
nostra cellula rimane nuda se volete e
con il virus che abbiamo addomesticato
inserire finalmente è soltanto il nuovo
recettore che la porterà verso il tumore
in modo a questo punto più efficace e
formidabile rispetto agli approcci
precedenti c'è infine un traguardo
ancora più ambizioso che possiamo porci
poiché quando noi tagliamo il dna in un
punto specifico la cellula prima di
riaggiustare questo taglio e quindi
introdurre magari degli errori come ho
fatto io ho fatto vedere prima e quindi
distruggendo quel genere che abbiamo
tagliato cerca in realtà di ricopiare la
sequenza originale per ripristinare la
situazione di partenza è un modo più più
più sicuro di riparare allora anche qui
possiamo essere più furbi della cellula
e inserire una stampa un hack da copiare
che porti praticamente una sequenza
simile a quella che abbiamo tagliato ma
con il cam con la modifica che volevamo
introdurre in questo modo la cellula
ricopia la nuova sequenza il post
originale abbiamo fatto quello che noi
chiamiamo l'editing in qualche modo
immaginate un tipografo che lavora su un
foglio delle istruzioni e riscrive
quelle stesse istruzioni magari
correggendo una mutazione genetica o
inserendo quindi una nuova funzione in
modo così mirato e preciso siamo qui
davanti a un nuovo campo che si apre
alla medicina molecolare dove per la
prima volta il farmaci diventano
qualcosa di molto più complesso di
farmaci fino ad oggi sono stati piccole
molecole che in qualche modo basano la
loro funzione sul fatto di legarsi a una
un'altra superficie molecolare oppure
sono in certi casi delle molecole più
complesse qui il farmaci sono geni
quindi sono informazioni per fare delle
proteine
informazioni che tra l'altro si possono
controllare possono fare sì che una
volta somministrate queste informazioni
rimangono magari per tutta la vita di
quell'individuo a ripristinare la
funzione che prima non c'era non solo ma
in alcuni casi come nel caso delle
cellule che vi ho fatto vedere sono le
cellule stesse che diventano il veicolo
della terapia
quindi i farmaci diventano farmaci
intelligenti capace di muoversi
nell'organismo
stiamo imparando a sfruttare dei
processi straordinarie della biologia e
le cellule che sanno dove andare
le cellule che cercano il sito della
malattia perché hanno la loro capacità e
portano attraverso la terapia genica
la terapia in situ questo può essere può
aprire veramente un nuovo campo per
esempio usando le funzioni immunitarie
ed uccidere una cellula tumorale ma in
modo selettivo risparmiando il tessuto
si apre quindi un campo straordinario e
può portare una risposta terapeutica
molte malattie che oggi sono orfane di
un trattamento si apre anche una sfida
una sfida alla ricerca una sfida alla
medicina perché qui parliamo di farmaci
più che intelligenti quasi vivi se
volete se vivo può essere un virus
addomesticato che finisce la sua vita
una volta che entra nella cellula
dobbiamo imparare a manipolarli 15 va
prudenza ovviamente ci fa anche
competenza la competenza che intorno al
letto di un malato che riceverà questi
te queste terapie richiede diversi con
esperti quelli del ricercatore quelli
del medico e soprattutto anche a livello
societario
queste nuove terapie saranno una sfida
diventano terapie personalizzate le
cellule del paziente diventano il
veicolo della terapia ma devo imparare a
manipolarle e poi ri somministrarle
anche questo comporta costi gli impegni
ma di fronte naturalmente alla
prospettiva di offrire delle terapie che
fino a oggi non erano disponibili
dobbiamo però anche considerare gli
aspetti etici che ci pongono di fronte a
queste prospettive
siamo veramente del dominio della
tecnica ma quella tecnica che talvolta
si pone come unico dio a cui la nostra
società sembra oggi servire e se volete
ci ha anche aspetti inquietanti il dna
che vi dicevo prima quel manuale di
istruzioni che è diventato auto
cosciente nella nostra specie è che a
questo punto evitare se stesso può
andare a modificare
le informazioni anche questo
naturalmente un ambito difficile in cui
è importante sapersi muovere con
attenzione vorrei quindi conclude
ritornando a quelle stesse radici della
nostra cultura un pochino rifacendomi al
mondo greca con l'iscrizione sul tempio
di apollo a delfi che diceva conosci te
stesso conosci i tuoi limiti invitandole
se non noi scienziati e tutta la società
a riflettere profondamente
sull'insegnamento di questa di questa
verità la conoscenza che abbiamo della
realtà tutto il criticismo ce l'ha
insegnato e una conoscenza di relazioni
non è profonda non ci dà la chiave nella
verità ci dà soltanto la questione
intervenire predire in qualche modo e
quindi forse come il come scienziati
come ricercatore la nostra guida quella
che veramente può dare ragione al nostro
al nostro agire più di ogni altro è
quella di essere ispirati dallo scopo
traslazionale dal portare per esempio un
beneficio terapeutico quindi ricondurre
la nostra azione in un orizzonte che può
essere quello del dell'utile o se volete
anche del beneficio anche se volete che
lo religioso
grazie